in einem appell mit dem titel
waffenstillstand jetzt veröffentlicht in
der wochenzeitung die zeit fordern
bekannte deutsche persönlichkeiten wie
der philosoph richard david precht die
schriftstellerin juli zeh sowie
wissenschaftsjournalist ranga yogeshwar
einen konzertierten vorstoß führt
verhandlungen in hennef begrüße ich
ranga yogeshwar sie haben in dem offenen
brief politiker dazu aufgefordert den
russischen angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
durch verhandlungen zu beenden und zudem
stellen sie in frage ob
waffenlieferungen der richtige weg sein
warum was was erhoffen sie sich von der
aktion
wir erhoffen uns erst einmal dass wir
irgendwie ein ende dieses konflikts
irgendwie herbeiführen denn wir haben
momentan eine situation
wo immer mehr waffen hinein kommen wo
auf der anderen seite auch immer mehr
schäden entstehen das sind nicht nur
schäden innerhalb der ukraine viele
menschen die verletzt sind die tode
sterben die
flüchten müssen eine infrastruktur mit
enormen zerstörungspotenzial aber was
wir zunehmend sehen ist die
kollateralschäden dieses konfliktes am
globale auswirkungen man denke nur zb an
den hunger in der welt oder die tatsache
dass bei uns energiepreise anfangen auch
im inneren im sinne der des inneren
friedens
zunehmend ein problem zu werden naja sie
schreiben darin eine weitere fortsetzung
des krieges würde tausende weitere opfer
bedeuten und auch die humanitäre notlage
in der ganzen welt könnte sich zuspitzen
dann schreiben sie einen diktat frieden
putins dürfe es aber nicht geben ja wie
sähe denn ihre friedensidee dann aus
das steht eigentlich auch in diesem
appell drinnen es geht darum dass man
eine echte fokussierung hat auf
verhandlungen dass man eine wirklich
internationale anstrengung und zwar in
einer dimension wie wir sie bisher nicht
gesehen haben unternimmt mit dem ziel im
grunde genommen ein waffenstillstand
herbeizuführen
das ist nicht einfach aber ich sage ganz
offen ich akzeptiere nicht dass was wir
in den letzten vielen wochen gehört
haben nämlich nur zu sagen putin mit dem
kann man nicht verhandeln ja ich weiss
putin ist alles andere als ein einfacher
verhandlungspartner aber aus der
vergangenheit weiß man es gibt
verhandlungs
formate die dann doch erfolgreich sind
und ich glaube das wichtige dabei ist
eine haltung einzunehmen die anders ist
denn wenn ich das auch mal sagen darf
wir haben jetzt eine kommentierung zb
des ukrainischen botschafters der
twitterte ich darf wirklich mal zitieren
nicht schon wieder rote band auf pseudo
intellektuelle saß ihr alle warwick
schwarz kluges brechts yogeshwar syz &
co sollte euch endlich mit euren
defätistisch 'nen ratschlägen zum teufel
scheren tschüss also ganz ehrlich das
sind die worte einer offiziellen person
eines botschafters bei dem brief gibt es
menschen wie zb herr nida rümelin
seinerseits früher mal der
kulturminister weil man so will von
deutschland wir haben ein brigadegeneral
der frau merkel unterstützt hat und ich
finde an der stelle müssen wir auch
irgendwann mal achten welchen stil
solche diskussion auch bei uns annehmen
und ich finde ganz ehrlich nach so einem
statement sollte man eigentlich auch mal
in berlin herrn manic einberufen und dem
klarmachen dass in demokratien auch
unterschiedliche meinungen ohne
persönliche diffamierung durchaus
akzeptabel sind es gab ja auch etwas
besonnenere reaktionen der
militärexperte carlo masala zum beispiel
das auch nicht so ganz überzeugt er
schreibt der nächste versuch von
menschen bis auf zwei ausnahmen die sich
bislang nicht mit internationaler
politik beschäftigt hätten dinge zu
fordern ohne lösungen zu präsentieren
wie reagieren sie denn darauf
wissen sie der entscheidende punkt in
einer demokratie ist auf der einen seite
gibt es natürlich fachleute und auch bei
diesem brief gibt es fachleute die mit
unterschrieben haben es gibt aber auf
der anderen seite auch eine entscheidung
die letztlich auch und das ist schon in
demokratien auch durch die
meinungsbildung innerhalb der
bevölkerung getroffen werden muss und an
der stelle muss ich einfach sagen da
muss man andere anstrengungen
unternehmen zumal und das ist auch bei
diesem konflikt allmählich deutlich die
zielsetzung um was es am ende gehen soll
immer diffuser werten die us amerikaner
haben eine andere vorstellung als die
nato die wiederum zum teil eine andere
als viele europäische staaten und wenn
sie diffuse ziele haben und dabei aber
immer noch waffen liefern dann ist ein
ende nicht in sicht und ich glaube das
ist zunehmend wichtig vielen dank ranga
yogeshwar